that question the first person you ask
that question to is yourself do i love
myself for who i am or do i love myself
for what i do you're expecting other
people to do something that you haven't
done most of the time right you're like
i wish they would just love me for who i
am meanwhile i'm going to love myself
for what i do
holbry marcus welcome to the show thanks
chris happy to be here again man i know
dude congratulations on the marriage
yeah that's the big one right i mean i
was expecting on it to come out of that
but the big one is the marriage i got i
got my dream relationship i mean it's
stunning just layers and layers
of
beautiful complexity and uh i'm really
really
so so happy
man
that's amazing like it's especially to
do it during a pandemic as well
yeah i mean i think the pandemic is a
bit subjective you know everybody had
their own pandemic experience
you know for me it was
i've known vilana for many years so it
was actually like
i don't know
if our actions would have been that
different i mean maybe a few more
dinners out rather than cooking at home
but nonetheless when you get into this
kind of uh
you know passionate union
we were just gonna be spending a lot of
time together anyways
dude i love it man it makes me happy to
see you happy and it really does look
like you are yeah no doubt man no doubt
there's a video that i saw of yours a
little while ago i'm just going to read
out a transcript that i pulled from it i
spent so much of my life terrified of
what i was going to become and whether i
was going to be right here right now god
how much time did i waste afraid i
wasn't going to be right here right now
if i could change the only thing i'd
change about my whole life would be
fearing less that i wouldn't get here
the place that i was going anyway i
wouldn't change all those mistakes and
mishaps i needed those but all the
constant worried that i wasn't going to
make it that took me out of enjoying the
moment it took me out of enjoying these
experiences smiling or eating my lunch
or doing whatever i was doing
know your mission have faith you're
going to get there wherever you go it's
going to be all right just find ways to
get out of your head
what's that mean to you
this is the constant ever-present
reminder advice that i give to myself
and as many times as i say it i need to
say it one more time
because this is this is the task this is
the challenge you know i don't want to
go to the end of my life and say i did a
lot of good stuff but i never really
enjoyed any of it because i was always
worried about the next thing that i did
and that's how i've lived so much of my
life it was always been about projecting
my mind in the future solving future
problems figuring out what i was going
to do next
at the
cost of really being present with what i
was doing in the moment now
a lot of people might think that there's
a trade-off like it's one or the other
you're either just enjoying the moment
and you're just blissed out like you
know somebody who's high looking at
daffodils in the [ __ ] field or
something like that you know or you're
really focused but there's a way to be
really present in the actions that
you're doing and i've been able to touch
that thing and experience it in small
doses but i want to live that way i want
to still of course i'm going to be
thinking about the future thinking about
what i can build thinking about how i
can contribute to the world the world
certainly needs it now more than ever it
feels like but can i do that with my
heart full
and you know really
present with what i'm doing rather than
in
anxiousness or fear or concern about
whether it's going to work whether i'm
doing enough all of these thoughts of
the mind and just move forward with this
kind of confident
knowing that i'm here i'm doing my best
and that's all that matters and uh it's
going to it's going to happen as it
happens which it always has that's the
thing like i'm batting a thousand like
i've never struck out you know like i've
always whatever even if i've made a
mistake even if i've fallen on my face
i've learned from it it's all been
perfect but nonetheless i look ahead to
the future with this anticipation of
maybe this time i'm going to fail and
the failure is going to be the worst
thing that's ever going to happen it
never is so it's like getting out of
these patterns
and that's my um you know that's my
prayer that's my daily constant reminder
and prayer and i have to go back to it
all the time where do you think that
comes from is it fear
it is fear
there's a deep deep fear i recognized
early on in my life that i had
unbelievable potential and advantage i
mean my parents were all exceptional in
what they did my father a top
commodities trader my stepfather a swat
team squad captain my mother a
professional tennis player made it to
the semifinals of wimbledon my
stepmother uh top nutraceutical doctor
who's working with pat riley's teams
like i had
amazing mentors in my family you know i
had a lot of natural aptitude i was
speaking and using language you know at
one years old like in
a pretty astounding way like it just
language came really easily to me the
way my mind worked my body's been really
healthy i've always
so many advantages and i've recognized
that
and with that i've realized like i've
got to do some [ __ ] important [ __ ]
you know like i don't want to squander
this and i really love i love life i
love people i love the world so i love
the world i know what i'm capable of and
so the biggest fear comes
maybe i'm not going to do enough maybe
i've been given
yeah exactly i've been given all of
these advantages all of these blessings
i better do something [ __ ] epic you
know and maybe i won't maybe i'll fail
and that's the that's the constant fear
i've i've gone into my own
fear of death you know ayahuasca has
really helped me with that and i don't
believe death is anything like people
think death is it's just a transition to
a really beautiful place so i don't
really worry about death so much
of course you know i don't wanna i don't
want death i don't wanna i don't wanna
experience that but what i'm really
afraid of is i'm afraid of
not doing enough and that's the fear
that i'm currently
still still [ __ ] still working on is
like this really trusting that it's
enough whatever i do it's enough after
the marriage after the company sale
after the
so on and so on and so on
still there
the thing is there's no external
satisfaction to this to this mental
construct there's nothing that i could
do i could literally
come up with some
philosophical treatise some
you know some
documentary or some book and the book
just
you know is like a sonic boom around the
world and shifts consciousness radically
and i would still be like
what's my next book this isn't enough it
doesn't [ __ ] matter right like it
doesn't matter there's no satisfaction
to
this drive to do more and this fear that
i'm not doing enough
so i have to go inside internally and
and that's that's where the real work is
it's in the privacy of my own mind and
heart because i'll never and nobody can
satisfy internal
fears and desires with external
realities well that's what people
presume right we look to the challenges
and the inadequacies that we feel that
we have and the validation that we think
that we need and we look to the outside
world okay well if i can tick this box
and this box and this box and this box
then maybe i'll finally feel like i'm
enough or maybe i'll finally have
confidence that i'm going to be able to
continue and actually complete the
things
that i want to do
and yet
the adaptation is a hell of a drug man
like it just doesn't seem to slow down
it just keeps on coming no
no
yeah i mean it's
selling on it was a huge win first of
all i built the company in my dreams can
you explain for people that don't know
what what's happened recently what's
happened there
so
2010 um i
founded a company called on it and the
idea was total human optimization it was
about putting all of the best things you
could
into supplements into functional foods
and then really bringing you know
bringing to the masses this idea of
unconventional fitness kettlebells steel
maces and steel clubs which come from
12th century persia and old training
methods and battle ropes and all the
different you know ways in which the
body moves like the body is designed to
move and then supporting it with these
rare botanicals and nutritional herbs
and then bringing those to clinical
studies to prove the efficacy things
that you could really feel
and then more than that just an ethos an
ethos about
being a little bit better tomorrow than
you are today you know like that's the
that was always the idea like we can
strive for more we can bring more out of
ourself become more capable reach our
potential and no matter who you are
where you are like you can be on it you
can be the best version of yourself and
your best version is as good as
anybody's best version so it's really
positive
idea and also disruptive ideas about how
to treat your customers you know we had
a return policy where people didn't even
have to send their product back they
could just be like yo i didn't like it
we'd give your money back like really
honoring
everybody with real reciprocity
built that
and took it as far as i could possibly
take it until i couldn't take it any
further myself and i recognized that and
was able to exit and sell to a big
global company called unilever and
they're going to take it global around
the world already plans to really push
on it into markets that we just didn't
have the capability to reach so
everywhere from uh even it's it's odd
but like australia and canada it's so
hard to sell stuff there like it really
is why there's you know well there's the
tga therapeutic goods association in
australia there's health canada and
canada and then there's nation each and
then the uk has a whole [ __ ] mess of
things in germany you have to have a
prescription to get vitamin c it's like
it's like great like vitamins or
prescription drugs in germany it's like
very
it's very complicated from a regulatory
standpoint but on it is a it's a
global disruptive movement it's a
movement and so like i couldn't take it
any further so
you know these you know our new our new
acquirers can and so it's like an easy
choice like all right and they've
left the the team entirely intact it's
still exactly it's the it was the dream
you know and also
the massive resources that that's
allowed me to have
so this whole process happens and this
is like
you would think that after that i could
be like and then aubry rested
no no not at all people were like how is
it after the sale of honor i was like i
don't know it's [ __ ] stressful i got
all these resources now and i feel like
i have to do 10 times as much because i
have all of this potential to do even
more and i'm [ __ ] going crazy you
know it's like and that's my own fault
you know and so it's because
it's just i haven't escaped that kind of
mindset it's just as much as i'm capable
of doing then i put pressure on myself
to do even more
it's weird that when you have more fuel
in the fire that it doesn't it doesn't
sort of make you calm down it decides
okay i'm just going to build this bigger
i'm going to try and get the rocket to
go further and there's almost a
there's almost a pressure
around the fact that you feel like you
need
to do you feel like you need to achieve
with this now that you have these extra
resources
because most people would think you know
you wake up you look at the bank account
that morning like did you feel any
different on the morning of the day that
everything went through
there was this sense of like holy [ __ ]
like it really happened like it really
happened
that was that was real and that took a
little while to integrate and set in but
i didn't give myself much time i mean it
was there's a lot of als
it's not like
it's almost like there's pressure there
was mad pressure you know because first
of all i have all of this all of this
liquid resource i've never had all of my
real wealth was tied up in the stock in
in the equity and on it right that was
that i mean i got paid from on it but
whatever but that was it was a different
level now i have these liquid resources
like okay i got to figure out how to put
these in in safe places you know like
what am i going to do with these
so that was like a first little scramble
where i'm like figuring all that out and
then from there
tons of you know tons of different
charitable options things that i haven't
been able to do donating this to maps
for this new study donating this to this
quiet group in brazil that's really kind
of holding the candle for an island of
sanity and and and consciousness that
you know nobody knows like all these
little from obscure to really present
you know in in kind of obvious ways to
to donate money so there's been that
whole rush and then there's been
investments and different ideas and
startups that i really believe in
and then there's just this idea of like
okay
now i have all of these resources as you
said it's like if i was i don't like war
analogies but it's just the easiest to
say it's like if i'm a general and my
goal is to spread love to the world i
have now the resources like uh like one
of those video games like those sim
video games where you can like build
your little
resources you've got the unlimited
do you want tanks or dragons or
drawbridges or [ __ ] moats or like i
have all these resources like i gotta
build i gotta build what am i doing i
gotta build
and uh and so it's it's been an
interesting time
what about the validation the desire for
validation the last time that we spoke
there's this naval ravicant quote that
came up that said it is far easier to
achieve your material desires than to
renounce them
is there
is this an answered question for that
with you now does that does it feel like
there's any sort of a door closed at all
the desire for validation for me was
mostly with women
right like that was always the that was
always the biggest
the biggest hurdle and i think it was
one of the driving forces behind my
desire to be in that polyamorous
relationship before i got married
was
i had this insatiable desire to be loved
by the feminine and so one partner
loving me was not enough but maybe two
partners loving me was enough well that
wasn't quite enough but three's the
answer three [ __ ] he would do it
what about that fourth though could i
and then meanwhile everybody hated me
you know the polyamory is really really
hard and it's not because i did anything
wrong it's just it's really hard it's
really really hard to manage all that so
it was a beautiful uh it was a beautiful
experience
and i wouldn't trade it for anything but
that was really where i was seeking
validation the most
and i think one of the things that has
really settled was
you know my marriage with vilana that's
that she is my dream girl in every
possible way and so
there's a whole area of my life where
i'm like okay
this thing i did it there's nothing more
that i need to do like i i hit it i
nailed it you know and that's
one of at least in one area of my life
this insatiable quest for more
has been settled it's been quelled
and and with that a lot of the need for
validation now it's not that i don't
have some of that you know i mean
there's
there's still
a desire to be validated by my own
standards of
what i think i'm capable of right so
really i'm still fighting my own
internal judge that's saying
are you doing enough
are you doing enough how about i don't
know you were you're watching a movie
better bring your laptop out because you
could do something while you're watching
the movie
which is crazy right just watch the
[ __ ] movie and do something later but
i still i still wrestle with that
do you worry that now that you're in a
relationship and that you're so happy
if you said that a lot of your
motivation came from this desire for
validation are you concerned that that's
going to quench some of that fire
well it has
it has in a way
so
that's a great question and uh i just
want to take a moment to acknowledge
you know your mastery as a podcaster
because i do a lot of interviews but
really that's a really good question a
lot of these have been really good
questions
the thing is is that a great part of my
motivation for my life for everything
that i did let me tell you i'll start
with a story so i was
i was
such a frustrated romantic for all my
whole life at least until i was 20 21 i
started to have a little success but up
until 21 it was just a litany of
rejection
every girl i like i would write them
poems i would
make go to a glass blower and have them
blow a
glass rose and then be like uh thanks ew
and every single one i would like shower
them with praise and love
no nobody really likes that at the start
i mean there's a time and a place for
that but i was going in with too much
niceness too much like i love you you
know right off the bat and it was just
constant rejection now i had girlfriends
but they were always the ones that were
like my buddies while i was going after
the one that i really liked
and they'd be like hey i like you and
like yeah i guess i like you too yeah i
guess you're convenient as well yeah
yeah so i mean they were great but it
was never the one that i like really
really liked and it's just
constant just constant rejection and
so i was 21
and this was before anything started to
turn
and uh and and it was also frustrating
because i was a star athlete you know i
was always i was like doing all of the
things that i thought like if you watch
the movie grease or something like i was
like [ __ ] i'm the i'm the guy like i'm a
captain of the team you know varsity
three years i'm crushing it and all
these what's what's the problem here how
come i'm constantly getting rejected
so i go to
i go to this show in vegas and it's
based on the crazy horse in paris it was
called la pham and it was at the mgm
grand and i'm 21 and i'm sipping on uh
like some scotch
and and i'm watching this by myself in
in las vegas and i'm looking at these
incredibly beautiful dancers and it's
like a burlesque show and they're doing
this whole burlesque show with this
projection mapping and lights and
amazing show
and i just start i just start crying and
this like tears start coming down my
face and i'm sipping my whiskey and i'm
just making this solemn vow with the
universe i'm like i will do whatever it
takes to be the type of man that could
ask one of these girls out and they
would say yes whatever it [ __ ] takes
and it was this vow to be like the very
best human that i could possibly be in
every way and you know from spiritual to
physical to mental to emotional to
financial to you know my prowess at
large and i made this vow but it was all
it was so that that mythical girl would
say yes
you know ultimately
and
so much of my entire life
has been for that purpose like
everything at least a little bit some of
it is for
the obvious like okay i like being
physically fit because i like to surf i
like to play basketball i like to do all
this i like to you know build a business
because i love the business i love what
i'm doing so there's a very pure
motivation and then there was also
this
internal desire to make myself more
appealing to the opposite sex always
always so i had like two engines
motivating me one was my service to the
world my enjoyment of life and the other
was like and
whatever i do is going to make me more
attractive so that i won't get rejected
anymore double win
double win right so but one of those
engines now that i've and in polyamory
it was the same both engines were firing
because there's always
there was always the potential for
another paramore another partner so
i get married monogamous my dream girl
that engine powers down
the engine that i've had my whole life
which is do more be more awesome and
girls will like you
power down my wife loves me
unconditionally like there's nothing i
need to do i mean
i'm gonna do stuff anyways i'm motivated
i have the other engine going but that
engine powered down and there was a real
vacuum there was a real vacuum of like
whoa i missed this
like i missed this drive
that i had for trying to attract the
opposite sex i mix it
so what i've had to do is i've had to
make the other engine more powerful i've
had to really focus on how much i love
the world and how compassionate i feel
for the people who are suffering
and there's been some advice from tom
bilyeu recently that's really helped
instead of making it abstract like i
love the world which is really hard the
world is huge and complex and the brain
doesn't work that way just think of one
person you know like i love this one
you can create it as a real person or an
avatar like i love this one
person who feels alone trapped in their
mind can't get through these mazes and
puzzles and can't open their heart and
if i can deliver this message to them
with my own heart maybe they can find
that peace and they can find that bridge
to their own love for their own higher
self and really just focusing on that
and so i've been in the process of
really fueling and building this single
engine and the engine of service like
really being of service and trying to
get that to be as powerful as my twin
engines
and uh and that's been that's been the
process but it happened at the same time
right so you had the marriage and within
the space of a year also the exit from
on it yep so
i mean from an existential crisis
standpoint i think
this is about is
this is like rx plus plus plus this is
the
this is the super navy seals seal team
six version
yeah this has been a massive year of
transition and i think there's it's no
accident that
you know i've done ayahuasca 25 times in
my life or so and nine of them have come
in the last seven months
[Laughter]
you know i've been
so i've
this is by far the most i've reached to
the to the plant allies and i'm actually
hiring a coach now i've never hired a
coach i've had a lot of mentors but i'm
like [ __ ] it i need a coach like i need
someone who can i can talk to every week
and
and really like help me sort through
because it's it's very complex the other
complexity is
i feel like
for most of my life
the world was it had its problems but it
was just kind of moving along i was just
kind of trucking along and
things weren't very prescient it wasn't
like urgent
and i could write a book about whatever
i wanted to write a book about and
people would benefit from it i could put
out stuff and it wasn't it was just
important but it wasn't urgent
now with what i see going on in the
world i feel like it's it's urgent like
there's an urgency so there's been this
all of this change all of this
opportunity and then this pressure the
stakes have just been raised as well the
stakes have been raised we're out of
again i don't like war analogies but
it's like we were in peace time and now
we're we're transitioning into wartime a
war for sovereignty and consciousness
and freedom and love and
breaking these divisions that people
have which come from both sides you know
one side calling the other side sheep
the other side telling them that they're
the unclean unvaxed grandma killers you
know like whatever and both sides losing
the humanity and the respect and the
reverence
for each other whether it's black and
white left and right
you know either way it's it's this
really kind of dangerous
division that's happening in the world
in in my perspective at least that's
like [ __ ] i got to really step up now so
it's all of these things all of my
transitions and then the pressure coming
in from the world
that's been a cocktail of
stress
man i feel that too
with the show with the messages that i
get you know even in the time that i've
been doing which is three and a half
years
there's a difference there's like a
there's a further there's an intensity
to some of the things that people say
now the desire for truth doesn't feel
like an armchair philosophy
luxury that people get to do as on a
sunday afternoon it
it feels like a necessity it's like
water and an oasis type thing you know
people need
guidance it really does feel like that
and then the thanks also feels more
existential it feels serious
and um yeah i think that you're right i
think that the stakes have been raised
and all of that together means you need
to work out who the new version of you
is and i'm interested in
what it means to let go of this old
identity because not only privately but
publicly as well sort of a lot of for a
period of time what you were was wrapped
up in the polyamory thing it was a very
public relationship or some of the
relationships you've had in the past
were very public
and letting go of that you were the
forefront of on it you know you were the
guy that drove it forward on the joe
rogan experience and talking about it
and then the podcast and all the
pre-rolls you know anybody goes back and
listens to an old episode of the podcast
it's you talking about the company that
is your company
all of this and you think okay so who's
the new identity and how do i let go of
the old one have you had any thoughts
about that
i really want to let go
of the identity
entirely and really touch it lightly you
know i mean i think ramdas is such a
great guide for our time you know really
one of the
the modern spiritual masters and you
know a big principle of his was becoming
nobody
right just becoming the force of life
itself and this is something that don
miguel ruiz talks about as well like
his ideal is to just remain faceless
just be the energy in the emanation of
life itself
identity is is useful but it's also a
trap it's like a useful prison
and
the aubry
the aubry
man the aubrey is [ __ ] it's tough
it's tough to be the aubry the author he
puts so much pressure on himself the
opry's like and it has so much
projection coming from the world about
what the aubry is
and uh
i don't like being the aubry that much i
mean it's great but i like being life i
like being in the present moment i can
wear the aubrey suit i love the aubrey
suit it's a wonderful suit you know it's
a wonderful it's a wonderful
appearance of god and drag right like i
get it i'm super happy with it and i've
cultivated it and it has a lot of
advantages but nonetheless it's still
not fun for me to be aubrey it's a lot
more fun for me to be life expressed
through the aubry suit has that been
released a little bit now that you don't
have the excuse that you're the
figureheads that's driving forward and
trailblazing this company and growth and
progression and more podcast plays
because it drives more growth and more
progression
i mean i wish i wish but it's just
shifted it's just chameleoned you know
it's like it just adopts finds let's
find something new that it's going to
pursue right so instead of being the
instead of being the head this the ceo
of on it it's now
the founder of on it with the amazing
exit you know like whatever it's the
same [ __ ] thing it's just a different
hue of the same costume yeah and you
know so in these medicine journeys which
has really been a deep part of my path
for 22 years with the plant medicines
i
escape the bounds
of the aubryness and i become life and i
feel like [ __ ]
my heart opens
and i just feel in concert and
connection with all of life it's not
always comfortable it's like breaking
through all of these constricting you
know the cells like jail cells like
bursting through like and becoming life
itself
and that helps it helps like loosen the
grip of of what that aubrey is and
so that's been a big part of of the path
it's just like okay can i wear it
lightly instead of having it sucked in
and calcified and becoming like armor
like bone and callus like wear it like a
nice cloak
you know like that's how i want to wear
my identity because it doesn't really
matter externally i have to really
shift my own internal identity
like shift my identity to being
the emanation of life itself like really
just say like i'm life and with that
comes
this amazing state of inner being
because we're all life itself you know
like you or me living a different life
you are life itself as well and i am
life itself so we're inexorably on the
same team
and that message if i can and i've
really realized like i have to if i'd
live that and if i can be that
my message to everybody which is
ultimately that trying to tell people on
both sides of the spectrum here like
listen
your life their life
we are all on the same team
like stop
you know like stop fighting
it's all one
one force of life and the goal is
to play the infinite game
like can we keep this game board where
life can exist
alive and thriving and free
as long as we possibly can like that's
what we should all be dedicated
on team life for
team infinite game
it feels to me like when we're talking
about sort of energy internally versus
persona the external representation that
we give the world
the persona kind of it iterates right it
it does calcify kind of like a a
crabs shell
and it's not as fluid as what happens
inside the person that you are is
constantly changing the person that you
were yesterday and today is just
slightly different but the persona it it
cracks and peels in big batches right
it's completely flat for a very long
time and then something happens and the
pressure inside gets to the point where
you go i i can't continue to wear
this persona anymore the what is
happening inside is no longer congruent
with what i'm showing the world outside
and yeah i think that holding the
persona lightly that trying to seek
validation from what you're putting
forth into the world as opposed to who
you are one of my buddies um
was in australia not long ago and he
told me he's very successful guy on
social media and he has a huge following
uh it's james smith people that are
listening i'll know who it is this big
fitness guy and he said he went onto a
rock and he asked himself on some
psilocybin and asked himself two
questions and he said
do people love you for who you are or
for what you do
there's a lot of people that love him
for what he does
but he doesn't know how many people love
him for who he is
and that question seems to be the
bifurcation the dichotomy between
essence
and persona
like outwards representation of you that
is kind of static and unchanging until
you decide to crack it and then shed it
and then go again
and then the inner version and yeah the
more light that you can wear that the
the fewer layers that your persona can
consist of
i think that's probably a good way to go
and that question the first person you
ask that question to is yourself
do i love myself
for who i am or do i love myself for
what i do
right like you're expecting other people
to do something that you haven't done
most of the time right you're like i
wish they would just love me for who i
am meanwhile i'm going to love myself
for what i do
it can't work that way and i'm i'm in
the same boat you know like i'm i'm so
much love myself for what i do like i do
something that i feel is important and
i'm like
nice [ __ ] job i love you you know
meanwhile i'm not i'm you know i'm in a
different place i'm the same essence of
life but i'm like what are you doing
[ __ ] haven't done anything in the
last week all you've done is blah blah
it's not enough
so really focusing that question
internally and learning to love yourself
for who you really are there's a great
affirmation that paul selig who's one of
my spiritual teachers i've had on the
podcast a few times
he has you say i know who i am in truth
i know what i am in truth
i know how i serve in truth
i am here i am here i am here
when you say that and it's this
activation of like oh okay in truth i
know who i am i know what i am i know
how i serve and i am here and it's this
claiming this i am claiming like no i am
here
as the essence of life as the monad the
divine spark like
and really practicing that and loving
that because that is the thing that
doesn't change it can't be
some no one can shoot an arrow at that
no one can cast aspersions that you
can't cancel god you just can't you know
good luck like that's the that's the
reality and that's the that's the
place of ultimate safety that's the rock
that's the castle that's the
impenetrable place because nothing can
touch that thing and so if you can learn
to love that
then you can move through life from a
place of love
what i like about that is thinking about
the fact that
how self-berating we can be when we
don't feel like we've achieved something
the lack of love that we have for
ourselves if we've done the evening on
the couch and haven't taken the laptop
to answer the emails as they've come in
or you know decided to take a long
weekend off and didn't do work or
whatever it might be
but it's so
it's so fickle it's like we're on a
knife edge
our view of ourselves and the love that
we have for ourselves is so it shouldn't
be that fragile
it shouldn't be that your actions within
the last
36 hours
significantly determine your judgment of
your unself worth like that shouldn't be
the case and yet it absolutely 100 is
for me
absolutely is if i've had if the last
podcast that i've done is awesome
i'm patting myself on the back i feel
like i'm on top of the world i'm really
confident i'm going into the next one
i'm gonna get it this is the right path
this is what i'm doing i'm really
improving
and then if the last one that i did was
poor it's [ __ ] like self-doubt creeps in
imposter syndrome keeps in
lack of confidence creeps in
and you think
this is not sustainable it isn't
sustainable
for
my self-worth to be hinged on the last
success or failure that i decided the
last time that i stepped onto the pitch
did i win lose or draw and then that
determines the way that i'm going to
feel for the remainder of whatever and
this has been the same
throughout it doesn't matter what level
you get to or what game you're playing
with this whether it was for me the club
promotion game if the last event that we
ran was huge and sold out and everybody
loved it there was no problems they're
brilliant i felt great but if the last
event that we did was a little bit under
budget and we didn't make the money that
we wanted and i got complaints and there
was bad reviews on facebook in 2013 when
facebook was a big deal i'd feel crap so
this is just it's the same game ported
onto a new console now
you know or it's the same set of rules
but just in a different game and um
it can't be like that it doesn't scale
it is not a replicable healthy holistic
way to exist
and you know i think one of the reasons
we change is we suffer until we get sick
of suffering this is a form of suffering
like eventually we just get so fed up
with doing this like i [ __ ] can't
handle this anymore i'm done with it
and then you have to forge the new way
it's it's hard to do it just out of
inspiration like somebody listening
right now who's
young and you know been in this a little
while and has it hasn't really tortured
themselves that much yet you know
they're like that's a cool idea but for
for us that are just battle weary and
haggard like [ __ ]
how many times am i gonna do this how
many times am i gonna feel like [ __ ] i'm
[ __ ] tired of it
you know like we suffer until we get
sick of suffering and uh but you're
absolutely right they have that saying
you know you're only as good as your
last game
and i think
they're referencing what the fans
are thinking of you right and it's true
like you have a an athlete has a shitty
game and all of a sudden all the pundits
were like what's wrong with him blah
blah blah did he do this what is what's
going on and then they then they play
well and they're like he's back
you mean like a [ __ ]
view
yeah how [ __ ] is that but we do it to
ourselves just like you said like this
is this idea that we project onto what
the fans do which they do we do the same
thing you are the shitty people of
course your own shitty pundit yes
yeah exactly
exactly
[ __ ] man yeah i am
that's a really interesting insight it
really is
i think uh
having a more robust stable foundation
would do a lot of people a lot of good
because what you end up doing
is you end up performing for the critic
you end up proving the critic wrong
as opposed to trying to do the thing
that you're supposed to be doing
and you end up having these perverse
incentives the incentive that the person
trying to disprove the critic wrong does
is well i'll i'll work harder i'll do
i'll do more or i'll go bigger or
whatever whatever i think the [ __ ]
tonic to this poison is i'm gonna keep
on i'm gonna keep on drinking it and
you're like no no no you've now turned
the tonic into a poison as well
like you have managed to create a system
in which you are self-referentially
becoming some [ __ ] self-fulfilling
prophecy version of what you didn't want
to be and you're your own torturer i've
got a buddy who's in a band one of his
lyrics is um
i can't drown my demons they've learned
how to swim
and that's what happens
when you've pushed for so long that
you've actually become your own shitty
pundit
i love that saying man okay
they've learned how to swim
yeah that's the you gotta change the
pool you got to swim in a place you got
to go to a different place like that's
the that's the reality it's
this shift of identity is is radical and
it's painful because it requires
it requires you to
so the ego think of the ego like a it's
an like an entity
it's like a real entity you know and for
those of us in the medicine space we
have this kind of idea of entities these
astral beings that come and talk to us
or whatever but imagine it's like that
or may think of it like a ghost
and what powers
the ego entity
is your identification with it
when you choose to be it it has life it
exists
and it's real it's really real
and
it wants to stay alive
it wants you to identify with it because
it wants to live all entities want to
live but we are their respiration our
belief and our identification it's our
it's the respiration it's the only way
that it lives
so the moment that we pull our
identification away from our ego from
our identity it starts to freak out it's
like gasping for air like a fish out of
water like
i'm going to die i'm going to die and so
what does it do this is resistance this
is capital r resistance like steven
pressfield talks about this is the the
yitzhara like the you know the mystical
in mystical judaism this force of
resistance
and
it'll drive you into fear or it'll come
up with something i mean i watch my own
ego do this as i retract every time i go
and do ayahuasca my ego [ __ ] freaks
out that this entity like freaks out
because it knows it's going to get
obliterated at least temporarily so it
starts going crazy it starts like it's a
the phenomenon in psychology is called
intrusive thoughts i start getting these
rapid fire intrusive thoughts like
uh go jump off that bridge and smash
this glass schizophrenia people with
schizophrenia have right
and that's a very extreme schizophrenia
is painting a reality that's that's
actually you know a belief in a
different reality i thought the
definition of schizophrenia was
intrusive thoughts i think it was
uncontrolled intrusive thoughts i might
be totally wrong here maybe
what i understand of intrusive thoughts
is they're they're quick and what i
experienced is their quick rapid fire
thoughts that actually drag me out of
the present moment it's like
it's like take this bottle and smash it
on the desk
i'm like why am i thinking about that
you know like
take your phone and throw it into the
jungle you know like i'm like no i don't
want to do that you know like like it'll
be all of these like little random
things and then it only happens when i'm
when i'm about to do ayahuasca right
it's like
and finally i realized like oh i
understand this is the ego entity trying
to distract me so i get like i get lost
from this place of like release
and this this is this is a it's a force
and so with that though but with that
awareness
it doesn't bother me i'm like okay i
understand baby like i understand little
ego entity like i know you're trying to
distract me by telling me to you know
create a shank made out of glass like i
get it
you know i get it you know it's all
right and then it starts to like slow
down but that's the that's the reality
of our of our ego construct our persona
all right this identity we create this
avatar of
of this self that we created it's alive
when we identify with it but as soon as
we start to pull away from it it starts
to die and it starts to freak out
it'll never actually fully die you know
you'll always have it but the
transformation
this is where the myth of the phoenix
comes in you burn it down and then a new
bird emerges from the ashes and i think
that's that's the best we can do but
holding again that's why allowing this
current construct to die knowing that
another one will rebuild until
eventually
you have like you're just in a closet of
identities you know just which coat do i
want to put on
and you're just really comfortable
because you who you are is beyond
identity you know and and then and
that's really the place that i'm
reaching is
and it's been a it's been hard recently
i mean this last ayahuasca journey was
the hardest i've ever had because i
think
my ego got to a place where it was like
the most tenacious it really liked its
current persona and form
and it really didn't want to go and so
i really had to like it was really
wrestling with me
and finally in the last ceremony it was
absolute obliteration
and death and then a new
a new form is now still emerging it's
still building and i'm a little shaky
and i'm a little
i mean things are like i feel a little
vulnerable like because the this persona
is helpful it's also an armor it's also
like a way to navigate life
you know and it creates this thing and
it also is a way to
it's just a way to navigate the world
and this new thing that i'm forming like
this new spaceship
of ego identity hasn't been fully formed
yet so
i'm in kind of this interesting place i
appreciate it but um but i think that's
the process it's just die and be reborn
die and be reborn constantly
how do people know if they're ready
for plant medicine let's say that
there's someone who's listening who is
familiar with breadth work practices and
meditation and they've done
level zero
as dan engle would say right they've
done the they've done the buy-in
um
what would be some of the signs
that people should be looking out for to
suggest well
maybe this is the sort of thing
that would be assisted by some plant
medicine
well the traditional the traditional
answer is that there's a calling there's
just a feeling that you have there's a
part of you that is
just irresistibly attracted to these
medicines but it's really hard to
describe it further than that you know
and then you get the question well what
is the calling how do i know if i have a
calling because simultaneously you're
going to have resistance so there's
going to be an attraction and then
there's going to be resistance what's
what's that is that a sign that you
shouldn't do it because your body's
telling you no maybe or is it just the
natural resistance and you really want
to say yes
i think the
the best way is to just have courage to
continue to to continue to lightly step
forward that way i mean you can just
dump jump in the deep end and
book a book on ayahuasca trip with the
with the dragon or
you know go
do some big ceremony i highly recommend
if you're gonna do anything big do it
with the best of the best like really
find a world-class
um
sitter shaman practitioner that you can
sit with
but otherwise just kind of
creep your way creep your way towards it
and i think again escalating those
breath work practices there's a guy um i
think the best best breath work
practitioner that i know of a guy named
lucas mack
l-u-k-i-s m-a-c
and i sat with him and did some breath
work there's ways to take breath work
really deep like really deep you know
where it's beyond level zero you're
going into the real
real level so
like take that really far and then start
creeping into different different plant
allies
ketamine is an interesting one to start
with
you know if you get it's now legal in
the u.s
it's a good way to just kind of feel the
bounds of selfhood dissolve and start to
experience the void in a somatic way and
it's very comfortable typically now it's
not so that's like an interesting way to
creep in like a 100 milligram fast
dissolve of ketamine like all right
let's just like creep into this and one
of the best combinations of medicine
actually
i think it's my current favorite
combination of plant plant medicine or
psychedelics is
ketamine and cannabis together both
legal in most places in the u.s but that
stack
it feels like it brings the body into
the void where ketamine is taking you
and it's a really really interesting
experience it doesn't last too long you
just have you don't and don't overdo it
you know have like one puff of flower
100 milligrams some great music you know
john hopkins has a new album that's
coming out called music for psychedelic
therapy it's [ __ ] stunning east
forest has some amazing music put on
some good music
you know get a blindfold get a mind fold
you want a mindful blindfold it's one
where you can open your eyes and it's
still completely black
so get one of those get some good
headphones and just like ease into it if
you're going to do it on your own and
that's a good way to start and then you
can also do a psilocybin journey with
somebody who's had some experience like
if you know uh you know
someone like you or i you know who's
been in this a lot like but start small
you know like don't [ __ ]
don't try to burn the house down right
out of the right out of the gate just
kind of like minimum effective dose get
comfortable with it
and i think that would be the way to go
and if you feel called for more like all
right i'm into this like i'm [ __ ]
into this
just don't be in a hurry you know i
guess would be my advice is just kind of
tiptoe your way
through
uh you have your whole life you know you
don't need to you don't need to rush
into anything and if you do feel like
just diving in because you just can't
handle it anymore
really go for the best of the best
you like is it saltara that's one of the
places that you tend to go to
sultana i think is practicing at the at
the highest level i actually flew in my
very first shaman
for a private retreat his name is
maestro orlando uh you can check him out
in peru he's it's actually i built a
redirect for his site it's maestro
orlando.com his nickname is el dragon de
la salva the drag the dragon of the
jungle and he's
he's the best shaman i think that
i i mean he's the best shaman i've ever
i've ever
encountered i mean i've been with some
amazing shamans maestro alberto is also
an absolute wizard you know like
incredible and he has a new center
that's opening up as well but for me
working with uh
maestro orlando is is just the best
however soltara has amazing shipibo
healers and the shipibo style is it's a
unique style it's a very traditional
you know ancient style that's been
brought forward and it's it's also
stunning so
but i really trust zoltar i really do
and i've sat with the shipibo healers
there um
maestro marina and maestroteo or the
people that i work with there
beautiful ceremonies really beautiful
impeccable ceremonies and great
facilitators great facilities at soltara
i highly highly recommend
uh for anybody who's looking like check
out sultara i think they're i think
they're the best in the game right now
i love it man
looking back at your period of
non-monogamy now as a happily married
man woman of your dreams
does that reframe that sort of
experience do you have a different sort
of view of non-monogamy generally now
was it just part of a journey where's
your head space out with that
it's uh it was definitely part of a
journey it's definitely part of like a
deep learning practice i mean we all
have jealousy to a certain extent
you know it's just inherent and if you
think you're not jealous i dare you to
get into a non-monogamous relationship
where your sweetheart is getting [ __ ]
by somebody else in your home alone and
just imagining what's happening like if
you can do that like
[ __ ] get an ashram somewhere like i
don't i don't know i don't know what it
takes to be able to handle that but
you know so you really confront the
dragon you confront the dragon of your
own jealousy like the the thought of me
being jealous in my current relationship
now with mylana is absolutely
preposterous because i've lived in the
worst case scenario
you know like i've lived the i've lived
the absolute nightmare
of of you know jealousy
so many times that i'm liberated from
that it's just not in the it's not in
the spectrum of possibility of what i
would actually worry about and that's
the that's one of the beautiful things
that you'll get from it
and that's what happens when you go head
first into your deepest fears or your
deepest challenges it's like the
ayahuasca of jealousy right you're
[ __ ] you're in it
so that's beautiful
it's also beautiful that i mean i got to
experience so many amazing people and
actually
i was only able to meet my wife and
become friends because i had the freedom
of a non-monogamous container like if i
wanted to go out on a friend date or
whatever with vilana like there was
never any question because i had
multiple other girlfriends so it's not
like there was an issue you know like i
was really free
so
i think it's it's a great path to
overcome jealousy it's also a great path
if you're not quite sure i loved whitney
a lot but it something wasn't just quite
right you know she's amazing whitney's
[ __ ] incredible
but it wasn't quite right for either of
us
and we've both actually subsequently
after since splitting you know we're
still friends but both of us have really
come into our own in a beautiful way
she's a country singer now you know and
she's like using her voice and she's
recording songs and songs are amazing
and i've always always wanted to sing
but in our relationship it just that
never emerged like there was ways in
which we weren't clicking for each
other's future
so the fact that we chose non-monogamy
was perfect because we were both free to
explore different people and learn
different things and it was it was
beautiful i got to meet some amazing
amazing humans you know stephanie and
savannah and maya and so many like
awesome people that i'm just so grateful
that i got a chance to experience
so that you know there was those are the
benefits
of it
we also made a lot of mistakes
um
one of the things that non-monogamy
requires is
perfect blisteringly honest
communication
like any little way in which you're
withholding the truth
becomes
explodes into a nightmare so it's also
great for practicing your honesty
like you really have to if you have
feelings for somebody or you think
something you feel something you have to
express it because the only safe place
you have is the truth and as soon as the
truth gets a little twisted
everything is in question and nothing
makes sense and you're just lost
so it's it's kind of a forging process
can i see it as
a
viable long-term solution
i can but it requires
the very best it requires a group of
people who are out there operating at
their very best in in heart and mind and
spirit and i think it can be a really
beautiful sacred non-monogamous union
uh i was never i was never quite good
enough to be honest i was never able to
really get there and i tried i tried
hard eight years you know and i gave it
everything i got i was not the type of
person that was capable of holding that
indefinitely
i never transcended my jealousy i never
got to the place of compersion which is
getting pleasure from someone else's
pleasure sustainably
you know like
if whitney's having a
orgasmic blissful experience with uh
with another lover
i was never like oh babe
i'm so happy for your orgasmic blissful
experience
oh are those
hand print bruises on your ass it must
have been passionate
passionate when he was spanking you that
hard i i'd love that you were that into
it with him no i was never like that i
wanted to vomit you know i just i
couldn't do it you know so but that
doesn't mean that it's not possible to
do
you know it doesn't mean that
my failures mean that the the whole
construct is flawed because i think the
construct is beautiful
but for me
it was just too hard
i think there's a definitely a
difference in my mind between using it
as a tool
to prepare yourself for a potential
future relationship
and
attaching your colors to the mass pole
and saying right this is me for the
remainder of time
in
my experience
spending a lot of time around a lot of
people
you need to be an incredibly unique
individual for that to be the right path
for you to go down long term i mean even
for you to go down it for two weeks you
need to be a pretty unique individual um
but for you to be able to look back
after
potentially an entire lifetime of
non-monogamy and say yes
that was the right choice i think that
you have to be
very very a significant outlier and i
also think that there's probably far
fewer people than actually think it and
what's reassuring to hear what's kind of
nice to hear from yourself is that look
like this is something that you can
perhaps consider or try or look at
but it's not
it's not for life you're not married to
the non-monogamy for life you know if
you if you want to bail out if you want
to make an exit plan at some point
you can do that
and
yeah one thing that i had in my mind is
it
so you've mentioned about the fact that
the jealousy was something one of the
sort of key emotions that you struggled
with and that
this was kind of like exposure therapy
for jealousy turned up to a million
is there any part of you
that
has echoes of that because that can be
so traumatic to the point where
it starts to embed a habit it starts to
embed a routine that the jealousy
actually starts to rear its head and
it's got all of this
foundation and this power and this
velocity behind it because look at all
of the things that you've done in the
past
do you ever notice that do you ever feel
that
you know the the thing about it is
the jealousy i think jealousy becomes
really toxic when it's imagined
right like imagined jealousy
you're just thinking and you're you're
waiting for this
dishonest way in which someone is
betraying you is that because you didn't
know do you think that's because of the
shame or the guilt around the fact that
you know that it's it's this part of it
that's not true and that there's almost
a little bit of it that's making it your
fault if the jealousy doesn't actually
exist if there's no real reason for it
to be there the shame because it's you
that's causing it
yeah i think that i think that's a
factor i also think that that's like
that's the difference between
polyamory and just a regular
relationship where you're jealous a lot
of times in a regular relationship where
you're jealous you're just creating all
kinds of fantasies of
things that are not real and so you
pattern this fantastical creation of
these jealous circumstances
you know this is what you see all the
time were you looking at that girl where
uh do you have what what what are you
what are you doing with that trainer you
know like do you like him you're like
blah blah like no he's just my friend
like blah blah blah because you're
creating all these fantasies
the the beauty of what i experienced was
it was all real
like she was really having
blissful orgasmic experiences with men
for real and would tell me about it as
you know because we're honest and then
she was really falling in love with her
boyfriend
ricky and really like all of these
things were really happening
so
while it was hard it was honest and i
think anything that's hard and honest is
productive and not traumatic
it's just productive right it's just
it's kind of like going into a sweat
lodge i don't know if you've ever done
like a really intense temescal or sweat
lodge nope
pitch dark you know you're in there
three hours
no water it's just prayers and heat and
they're pouring
water on these steaming rocks and
you feel at certain points if it's a
hard lodge like i don't know how i'm
gonna survive this like i don't know
this is so hot and i'm so thirsty and
i'm and i'm like just overwhelmed with
this and if you're with a real master
they know where the edge is and they
never obviously push it and of course
you could wave the white flag like i'm
not and they always make allowances for
that because it can be dangerous
but ultimately that's a super
challenging experience but you never
leave that traumatic you leave that
exhilarated because it's honest you
chose it you know what it is and you
endure it
and you come out and you're you're like
rebirth from the fire
and that's kind of the way that it is
with polyamory it's like it's real it's
like a sweat lodge like you know you
know when your partner is with that
other person you know and you know
what's how you know what's happening and
what's happening is worse than you hope
but not as bad as you fear right always
always that's like the universal rule
it's worse than you hope but not as bad
as you fear but if that's where it's
gonna that's what's happening
and and so it's
it's intense but it's not traumatic
what's traumatic is is like discovering
an adultery
you know like my my wife my wife had a
lot of trauma
not she was not she was monogamous but
on two of her birthdays she found out
that her boyfriend had impregnated
another woman that he was seeing on the
side the same boyfriend
two different ones two different
boyfriends both on a birthday
both on her birthday
what are the [ __ ] chances of that
that's right
yeah happy birthday i'm not going to be
here because i'm getting an abortion
with this other girl that you didn't
know i was seeing [ __ ] you know like
that's that's where the trauma comes
from like that's what imprints like deep
trauma because of the lack whereas if
it's
yeah it's the lack of truth whereas the
other thing is just
it's just a it's just a really difficult
initiation and that's that's kind of how
i feel so i actually look back at that
as hard as it was
i look back at that and there's like a
sense of almost a sense of pride
like yeah i [ __ ] did that you know i
did that i tossed and turned and i
wrestled in my bed and i puked and i
cried and i prayed to god and i made it
through
you know and like i did it
[ __ ] yeah you know it's like it's like
running an ultra marathon you know it's
hell but
i've never run one but i can imagine i
don't like running like two miles let
alone [ __ ] a hundred
but
it's the same thing like it breaks you
down but you're proud you're proud that
you went through it because you knew
what you were doing and you just you did
it
at the time was it ever in your head
that
you were doing something to become ready
for this sort of woman that you wanted
to spend the rest of your life with
no because i didn't think the woman that
i wanted to spend the rest of my life
with existed
i thought maybe it was vilana but she
never
she never really gave me any
any indication that she was interested
in that type of relationship until until
she did
i thought like maybe but i didn't know
her that well
intimately you know like we i knew her
as a friend but there was still a lot of
boundaries you know that she always had
she was very loyal to the people she was
seeing and
so i thought like look
here's my options either i compromise
with one person
or i just stay non-monogamous continue
to work on my jealousy get to be with a
bunch of different beautiful people
and i get to experience life and my
my
sacred union is with the great beloved
like rumi talks about like like all of
creation woman with a capital w embodied
in many different women
i really believe that was my future and
actually
interestingly i i think i finally got to
the place like right before vilana and i
got together i was like
i think i did it i'm [ __ ] happy
like i did it i'm happy you know and
like i didn't mind that whitney was you
know in love and seeing seeing her guy
still i i really didn't bother me that
much and she would go on dates and we'd
laugh about it and i had a bunch of
different dates that i was going on and
i was like
i think i made it i think i [ __ ] made
it
and then vilana came in and i was like
oh my god
this is the this is the path for me so
it took me by surprise
guys
i just didn't want to ever compromise
you know i never wanted to compromise
and vilana was the the absolute there
are no compromises it's like i had a
bingo card with 100 different squares
and the balls kept coming out and i hit
every single one
100 out of 100 and i'm like whoa i
didn't think that was possible
but it was it was for me and i don't
know if it is possible for everybody
the reason that i say it is i've been
thinking a lot recently talking to some
friends about
sort of becoming the man that you want
your future wife
to fall in love with you know creating
the life that you want to bring your
children into the world for being in the
place doing the work with the people
with the connections with the skill set
with the mindset with the balance with
the understanding of yourself and so on
and so on
and
it seems to me that
as
people get married or make commitments
to their life partners later and later
this is a luxury that we now have
and this is one that i don't really hear
very many people talking about the
opportunity to not only treat
your 20s and you know whatever period up
until you finally find the person you
want to be with
as time to explore and learn about you
and work out who you are but also to
become the person that you want that
family to be built upon especially as a
man
right you know sort of
load it up on my back like i'll continue
carrying like put more on put more
weight on put more weight on it's like
well if you haven't spent sufficient
time being able to build up your
tolerance you're not going to be able to
bear a very heavy load
and yeah i wonder
i think there's something there i think
there's something there
for men
in a crisis of masculinity age
to think okay
maybe you're not getting married at 19
to the
daughter of the daughter of next door's
farmer like anymore maybe that's not
happening
but
if you are a romantic if you do want to
lead a life in service of a family if
you know that you want to be a father if
you know that you want to be the
head of a household a leader somebody
that other people can look up to part of
your local community to have impact both
locally
uh familiary
familiarity whatever family and
in terms of your work and your
contributions there
if you want to do that you can spend
your time preparing for that
you can spend time becoming that sort of
person
being able to bear the load that you
know eventually one day you're going to
have to carry
i don't really hear i haven't really
heard much about that and it seems to me
although it wasn't done it definitely
wasn't planned that way
uh in the as you've just said like just
as you thought you got it all sorted out
someone came in and like sideswiped you
in an articulated lorry and completely
[ __ ] it all up again right going in a
different direction now um yeah
but it certainly seems to me sort of
reflecting on the non-monogamy period it
looks like
[ __ ] prep school prep school for
marriage yeah
yeah
absolutely
i mean i i think we need to do we have a
very comfortable life
we need to do hard [ __ ]
we need if we want to be the man that
can really hold as an anchor and as a
pillar in our in our family we need to
do hard [ __ ]
polyamory is is one of the hard things
and people don't really get it but like
to get them to get the benefit of
polyamory like there's the man's fantasy
right like oh you get to be with a bunch
of girls i'm like yeah i do
but i also all of these girls that i
have deep
love and feelings for they get to be
with whoever the [ __ ] they want and i
don't get to say no
you know like
like that's the
that's the work
that's where you're really in it
and i think there that's a hard thing
and that that hard thing forges you like
this is the iron that sharpens iron this
is the pressure and the heat that makes
diamonds
and it's just one of the ways you know i
think the plant medicine path is another
way there's
so many other ways that you can get you
know athletics doing hard things for
your body even a consistent cold plunge
practice talk about just something daily
that you can do where you look at that
cold plunge and you don't go like yeah
but you walk in like a [ __ ] king
that's what charles eisenstein says you
say you look at that cold plunge and you
walk in like a king
you know none of this like oh it's cold
let me huh just know you walk in and you
step in like a king and you drop down
and you submerge and you start your
breathing you do it like these things
these things are all forging practices
and they make us who we are so that
we're able to walk into those challenges
and those difficulties because they're
all going to come
you know whether it's you're in a
business and everything goes into chaos
some crazy [ __ ] happens and
you know you have to [ __ ] deal with
deal with
the surprise element
you know i remember
i remember one story from on it is uh
so before we produce you know our
flagship uh supplement was alpha brain
and one of the ingredients in alpha
brain is a greeting called oat straw and
it actually comes from oats
and
a venus sativa and so
the oats that we were getting were next
to a horse farm
and
and so
they uh the horses there in that farm i
guess some of them were racehorses
and so
ultimately we didn't we didn't really
understand the what that meant was like
all right whatever
so we tested the ingredient as it came
in
and there was
horse steroids
in our oat straw
right and this was a massive like this
was going to like kink up all of our
production for like a long time and
there's [ __ ] horse steroids in our
oat straw right
because
people were giving the horses steroids
they were pissing in the water and it
was getting into the oats
and i was like what the [ __ ]
you know this is all this chaos like
we're gonna be out of stock in alpha
brain like did any of this other we had
to go test former batches were horse
steroids in our old batches fortunately
it wasn't because we test you know
currently but it's these in that chaos
situation where everything's normal
everything's normal everything's normal
[ __ ] there's horse steroids in that
ingredient what the [ __ ]
you know how did this happen so you got
to go into that fire and it's just
but it's just like can i be as the
leader can i be the one that goes into
that and it just like holds everything
until
it's all sorted and it's all done and
then like three days later as
everything's kind of sorted out then you
can start laughing you're like
[ __ ] horse steroids like you're
kidding me i can't believe that but you
know it's just one example of like life
is gonna throw chaos there's just chaos
around and are you gonna be ready for
that in your business and your family
and one of the ways that you're ready
for that is just to emerge intentionally
into into the chaos into difficult
things and the things that make you the
type of person that can handle whatever
whatever comes at you
aubry marcus ladies and gentlemen you've
got a new book coming out what's
happening with that
hypothetically i got a new one
right now if you write the [ __ ] thing
then you'll be able to release it next
year right yeah it is it's a really
important book it's called master your
mind master your life
i've pushed off the release multiple
times and i'm about to push it off again
just because it's a very complicated
book because trying to separate the mind
from anything else is an impossible task
there's the mind and then there's the
body but really well the body informs
the mind in such an inexorable way and
the mind informs the body can you really
call them separate things or are they
the same thing is it just a different
density of mind so you start going
deeper and it's deeper like oh in the
mind and the spirit really mind in the
spirit like where's the [ __ ] line
that you draw there it's not everything
is blurred so ultimately coming to this
idea that it's you can either look at
you can really look at the mind like
everything is mine there's just
different condensations and densities of
how the mind operates
so really unpacking that and then
finding the ways to navigate
with all of the different articulations
of mine so i've really been
in the work you know really making sure
that i get this thing right uh
there was a lot of hubris when i when i
you know basically propose the book
master your mind matters i'll write a
book around the most complex organ that
we've got in the entire service yeah
exactly
so i'm i'm in it just uh that's all i
can say is i'm [ __ ] in it and when
it's done it's going to be awesome but
i'm not going to i'm not going to put
something out until i know and i know
that it's the it's the right thing to
put out cool aubry marcus podcast on
apple podcaster spotify wherever else
people listen and at aubrey marcus on
instagram brother thank you
thank you brother this was amazing
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe makes me very
happy indeed
peace